c'est Public
Sénat bonjour à tous merci de nous
rejoindre en direct du Sénat dans un
qu4h à 15h très précisément vous allez
pouvoir suivre les questions d'actualité
au Gouvernement beaucoup de sujets
aujourd'hui parmi les thèmes abordés par
les sénateurs notamment deux questions
autour de l'école et des rythmes
scolaires c'est le ministre de
l'Éducation Vincent payon qui répondra
directement à ces interpellations des
des sénateurs une question également sur
le déplacement la semaine dernière de
François Hollande à florenge c'est le
sénateur François grosidier sénateur UMP
de florenge qui interpellera le
gouvernement le Premier ministre mais
c'est jeunevè fe razo qui lui répondra
normalement une question aussi sur le
travail du dimanche autre thème
d'actualité important en ce moment et là
c'est Michel Sapin le ministre du
Travail euh qui euh sera présent et puis
à noter également une une question de la
sénatrice écologiste Esther ben Bassa
sur le contrôle au fciè c'est le
ministre de l'Intérieur manuel Vaz qui
sera présent pour lui répondre voilà et
puis après cette séance des questions
d'actualité on se retrouvera comme
d'habitude sur ce plateau avec nos
invités sénateur ministres euh pour
revoir ensemble euh ces questions
d'actualité refaire ensemble la séance
ensuite à 16h30 sur notre antenne vous
pourrez suivre toujours en direct la
suite de la discussion autour du projet
de loi sur les métropoles et une
disposition attendue en discussion cet
après-midi au Sénat puisque les
sénateurs vont aborder l'article 12 du
texte autour du Grand Paris Tam trin
nuit bonjour bonjour vous êtes avec nous
en direct de l'émicycle du Sénat
dites-nous un petit peu où on en est sur
ce texte sur les métropoles et ce qu'on
attend la discussion cet après-midi à
partir de 16h30 sur notre Antine autour
du Grand Paris donc on arrive au cœur du
texte effectivement puisqueen première
lecture rappelez-vous au mois de juin
les sénateurs avaient rejeté la création
du Grand Paris là où au contraire ils
avaient acté la création de la métropole
du Grand Lyon ou encore celle de
Marseille du coup l'enjeu de cette
deuxième lecture c'est bien le sort
réservé à la région capitale un enjeu
essentiel puisque c'est pas moins de 10
million et demi d'habitants que c'est le
premier bassin d'emploi européen alors
lors de cette deuxième lecture les
sénateurs UMP sont prêt au compromis
contrairement à ce qui avait été le cas
en première lecture plus de rejets en
bloc cette fois-ci l'objectif et bien
c'est bien d'imposer leur marque à ce
texte afin qu'il ne s'agisse plus qu'il
s'agisse pas d'une métropole simplement
décidée par les travaux de l'Assemblée
nationale leurs amendements visent
notamment à faire en sorte de préserver
les intercommunalités faire en sorte
qu'ell ne soit pas absorbé par la future
métropole du Grand Paris finalement les
mots les plus durs sont venus depuis 2
jours plutôt de la gauche de la gauche
du Front de Gauche des communistes qui
ont je cite dénoncé le dictat de
Bruxelles sur ce ce texte et qui
craignent la mise en place d'un monstre
technocratique merci beaucoup Tam on
vous retrouve en direct de la tribune de
presse de l'hémicycle tout à l'heure à
16h30 quand on va reprendre sur notre
antenne et bien les discussions autour
de ce projet de loi alors tout de suite
sur notre plateau Claude dyain sénateur
socialiste de Suns et puis Philippe
daller qui va venir tout de suite nous
rejoindre après quelques 30 secondes de
maquillage Claude dyin bonjour merci
d'être avec nous est-ce que vous pensez
que cet après-midi un compromis
politique va être trouvé ici au Sénat
autour du Grand Paris ah il est
fondamental pour le Sénat qu'un texte
concernant la métropole du Grand Paris
sorte on peut pas refaire le coup de la
page blanche on a vu que c'était
extrêmement difficile pour la métropole
de Paris mais c'était quand même pas
glorieux pour le Sénat qui a pu
légiférer sur l'ensemble du
territoire
dispitionè effectivement tout a été fait
pour que effectivement on puisse avoir
un texte et un texte équilibré et
j'espère effectivement parce que je
crois qu'il en va de l'avenir du Sénat
je dirai presque alors Philippe daller
les sénateurs P en première lecture
avaient rejeté les dispositions il y
avait une espèce d'alliance avec les les
communistes pour rejeter les
dispositions autour du Grand Paris
est-ce que là vous pensez qu'un
compromis politique va être trouvé en
seconde lecture cet après-midi autour de
cet article 12 é je rappellerai d'abord
que si nous avons aujourd'hui en
discussion un texte venu de l'Assemblée
nationale qui propose malgré tous ses
défauts on y reviendra la possibilité de
créer une véritable métropole du Grand
Paris c'est bien parce que le Sénat en
première lecture avait rejeté le texte
du gouvernement donc on a été beaucoup
critiqué pour cela mais c'est cela qui a
permis effectivement qu'on a aujourd'hui
un texte qui à mon sens est un Tex donc
ça a servi quand même à quelque chose ce
bien évidemment sinon on serait parti
sur le texte du Gouvernement qui voulait
une métropole de 10 millions d'habitants
dans une région qui en fait 12 donc
l'enjeu aujourd'hui pour le Sénat c'est
effectivement de savoir si on rendra à
nouveau une page blanche ce que je
n'imagine pas si on ira vers quelque
chose qui n'est pas une métropole c'est
la proposition d'un certain nombre de
nos collègues et moi je ne le souhaite
pas bah il propose un simple syndicat
mixte sans compétences très intégré et
surtout sans capacité enfin sans pouvoir
de lever l'impôt et je pense
qu'effectivement pour ce qui est d'une
métropole il faut un établissement
public de coopération intercommunale à
fiscalité propre pour qu'il ait des
moyens tout simplement manque d'ambition
autour de ce Grand Paris c'est ce que s
vous reprocherz philippe Dallier
claudin sur l'Anci
texte mais effectivement la question
était simple c'estàdire que le texte a
été rejeté donc qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'il fallait faire continuer avec ce
texte ou avoir plus d'audace moi j'ai
fait partie des sénateurs qui ont pensé
qu'il fallait avoir plus d'audace et
effectivement ce que le gouvernement a
proposé à l'Assemblée nationale est
effectivement un texte d'une métropole
intégrée qui a effectivement des
recettes fiscales et qui a des pouvoirs
et en particulier en matière de logement
on peut pas dire que le logement va bien
dans la métropole parisienne il va très
mal avec des conséquences humaines très
graves donc ne serait-ce que pour
logement mais il y a d'autres
compétences et et là il nous faut et les
transports notamment et oui alors ça
c'est la région il nous faut il nous
faut effectivement une métropole comme
partout ailleurs il suffit de regarder
ce qui se passe non seulement dans le
monde mais aussi en France avec la
métropole de Lyon dont tout le monde dit
que c'est extraordinaire alors il faut
que la région capitale est aussi une
vraie métropole je je rejoins tout à
fait Philippe daller d'ailleurs le Sénat
effectivement l'a démontré le temps du
syndicat mixte qui n'a pas beaucoup de
pouvoir est terminé rest qu'on est
toujours un peu perdu dans ce
millefeuille hein entre les
intercommunalités qui vont peut-être
disparaître au profit du du Grand Paris
mais les départements les trois
départements de la petite cour
parisienne devrait être maintenue plus
effectivement la structure ensuite
régionale est-ce qu'il faudrait pas
encore plus de simplification pour faire
un grand pôle central en France c'est
bien ce que j'espère et c'est bien ce
que j'avais proposé dans le rapport que
j'avais rendu en 2008 qui proposait la
création d'un Grand Paris en commençant
par fusionner les départements de Paris
et de la petite couronne et ensuite par
absorber les intercommunalités qui
existent dans ce périmètre on aurait
donc gardé les communes en charge de la
proximité la métropole essentiellement
en charge de l'urbanisme de la politique
de la ville du logement et puis la
région au-dessus et je pense que de
toutes les manières on va vers ce modèle
objectif 2020 2025 peut-être mais on va
vers ce modèle et ce c'est pourquoi il
faut qu'on adopte le texte qui nous est
présenté ici en tous les cas l'article
12 même modifié il faut qu'on l'adopte
parce que ça va dans la bonne direction
c'est pas le texte que j'aurais écrit
mais en tous les cas ça va dans la bonne
direction et c'est ce pourquoi je vais
me battre cet après-midi et vous êtes
d'accord tous les deux pour la
disparition des des strates
intercommunales bah bien évidemment
parce qu'on ne peut pas continuer d'c
tous non mais je pense qu'avec claudyin
on partage le même avis on ne peut pas
continuer à empiler des couches on
aurait les communes les
intercommunalités les départements la
métropole la région l'état l'Europe SEP
couches on nous dit qu'il faut être plus
efficace et que les Français n'en
peuvent plus des impôts qui pèsent sur
eux alors ça n'est certainement pas
comm rien du toutou oui d'abord un des
mérites de ce texte c'est
qu'effectivement il ne rajoute pas une
couche supplémentaire au milf ce qui
effectivement est très bien sur le
problème des départements moi moi je
pense que effectivement à terme il
faudra une suppression des départements
non pas une fusion ce qui peut-être me
me me me sépare un petit peu de de
Philippe Dalier mais au MO une supession
les haut scèes ont envie de fusionner
avec laassou probablement non mais
laassè s oui par contre
la très rare qu'un président de conseil
général disent j'en ai assez des
départements c'est quand même très rare
donc ça veut dire que la situation est
grave simplement nous on a fait la
démarche tivement inverse la démarche
intellectuelle et et et et
opérationnelle inverse de Philippe
Dalier parce que nous notre
préoccupation là notre priorité c'était
une métropole donc on s'est concentré
sur les compétences métropolitaines or
les compétences des départements qui
sont en gros l'aide social ne sont pas
d'ordre métropolitain donc nous avons
pensé que ce problème devait être remis
à plus tard parce que il ne concernait
pas l'urgence de créer une métropole
mais je je je partage la vie de philippe
Dallier je pense qu'à un moment ou à un
autre et dans des lapses de temps qu'il
qu'il dit je crois que ce qui paraisse
raisonnable il faudra se poser la
question soit de la fusion soit de la
disparition des départements ouais vous
vous y croyez une fusion possible de ces
trois départements la couronne
parisienne quand je disais fusion c'est
pour les faire disparaître au sein de la
métropole on est bien d'accord le but
c'est qu'il n'y ait plus que les
communes de la petite couronne et Paris
et au-dessus la métropole je pense que
c'est ça l'objectif qu'il faut atteindre
alors on y va pourquoi ne pas le faire
dès dès ce texte dès aujourd'hui écoutez
parce que c'est déjà une sacrée affaire
de faire adopter un texte en ce sens qui
trop embrasse mal lesrain on verra cet
après-midi que ça sera une à mon avis
assez difficile donc on peut y aller en
deux étapes mais le tout c'est de ne pas
remettre ça au calandre grec il faut
effectivement qu'on puisse d'ici 2020
avoir réaliser cette grande métropole
qui absorbera les départements de la
petite couronne et puis puis il y a des
problèmes techniques quand même he il y
a des personnels enfin c'est facile
d'int trer de plume sur le papier d'
REER de reayer les départements mais
après il faut comme les intercommunalist
on na pas encore tout réglé heureusement
il y a une mission de préfiguration
parce que rien que supprimer les les
EPCI les établissements publics c'est
déjà extrêmement compliqué ça pose ça
soulève un certain nombre de problèmes
techniques donc à chaque jour suffit sa
peine si effectivement ce soir je
rejoins une fois de plus devient grave
Philippe daliier pour qui
5050 donc si ce soir on arrive avec un
texte qui affirme l'absolue nécessité
d'un seul établissement public de à
fiscalité propre bien je crois qu'on
aura fait notre travail après on verra
il y a encore d'autres lectures il y a
la mission de préfiguration et puis dans
un 3e temps 4e temps on verra les
départements avec une entrée en vigueur
a priori en 2016 début 2016 est-ce que
ça c'est jouable oui je pense que c'est
jouable même si effectivement les
difficultés à surmonter seront
nombreuses parce que le texte que nous
allons discuter renvoie également à des
ordonnances parce qu'il faudra régler un
certainom de choses notamment en matière
fiscale tout ça est très compliqué mais
il faut bien se fixer des objectifs et
des objectifs de moyen terme il faut
bien se rendre compte que Paris au sens
large du Grand Paris c'est la dernière
métropole de France à s'organisé on a
créé les communautés urbaines il y a 40
ans ailleurs à Lyon à Lille et cetera on
n rien fait ici on a toujours envoyé à
plus tard justement parce que c'était
difficile donc maintenant je ne dis pas
pour quelle raison parce que Paris est
unique parce que Paris c'est la capitale
de la France parce qu'à Paris vous avez
énormément d'élus très importants qui
ont du pouvoir et qui parfois n'ont pas
envie de lâcher une partie de le pouvoir
tout ça ce sont des réactions humaines
mais ce qui est en jeu aujourd'hui ça
n'est pas seulement la question de la
région Île-de-France ou de la métropole
faire le Grand Paris c'est l'intérêt
national il faut que Paris notre ville
monde puisse rivaliser avec le Grand
Londres avec toutes ces grandes
métropoles il faut aussi penser à cela
c'est une question pour les habitants de
cette métropole mais c'est aussi une
question d'intérêt national vous avez
parlé de de fiscalité à l'instant est-ce
que vous pensez que les ressources qui
sont prévues par par le projet de loi
sont pour l'instant suffisantes pour la
naissance et la mise en œuvre de ce
grand oui je voudrais d'abord dire que
effectivement l'intérêt de créer une
métropole effectivement le rayonnement
de la métropole mais moi je fais partie
des gens qui pensent que il ne peut pas
y avoir de rayonnement si il y a dans ce
territoire des inégalités territoriales
aussi graves donc il faut que l'outil de
gouvernance que que nous allons créer
soit également en capacité de régler ces
graves inégalités territoriales un
champion d'Europe des inégalités
territoriales ici donc et ça on peut pas
rayonner c'est une espèce de boulet que
traîne la capitale donc effectivement le
fait d'avoir une fiscalité commune et en
gros de mettre un certain nombre de
recettes dans le même pot et après de le
redistribuer alors le redistribuer ça
c'est un acte politique mais au moins
avec cette métropole on a les moyens
techniques de faire la de la solidarité
après on la fera ou on la fera pas selon
les politiques ça c'est la démocratie
mais jusqu'à présent effectivement les
hautes scèes et la scène saint n'avaient
rien en commun en terme de fiscalité là
au moins on l'a ouais qu'est-ce qui
poussera plutôt ou NRE à redistribuer
leur fiscalité issue de du quartier de
d'affaires de de la vers vers la scène
saint-n bah écoutez lorsque l'on aura
une métropole avec des élus alors soit
représentant les communes c'est la
première étape soit peut-être après
issue du suffrage universel direct avec
un choix des électeurs et bien les
orientations politiques pourront être
différentes mais ce qui est certain
c'est qu'effectivement cette métropole
elle va bénéficier de tout l'impôt
économique collecté dans son périmètre
et c'est bien ça le plus important très
bien ben écoutez merci beaucoup à tous
les deux d'être venus sur notre plateau
je vous laisse reindre l'hémicycle du
Sénat puisque dans quelques secondes
quelques peut-être une minute ou deux
vont débuter maintenant les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement allez-y je
vous libère merci des questions
d'actualité beaucoup tourné autour de
l'école je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
deux questions autour de la refondation
de l'école des nouveaux rythmes
scolaires ces deux questions adressées
au ministre de l'Éducation Vincent payon
qui sera là dans l'hémicycle pour
répondre au sénateur manuel Vals
également sera a présent notamment pour
répondre à une question de la sénatrice
écologiste estben Bassa sur le contrôle
aux fciè euh Christian tobira la garde
des saau répondra à la première question
autour de l'aide juridictionnelle et
puis parmi les thèmes d'actualité
important en ce moment il y aura une
question sur le travail le dimanche et
ça c'est Michel Sapin le ministre du
Travail qui sera présent cet après-midi
au Sénat pour répondre à cette question
de la sénatrice communiste Annie David
euh enfin les chiffres du chômage avec
euh l'erreur commise par SFR la semaine
dernière et bien une question va être
posée par le nouveau sénateur UMP
Jean-François Husson là encore c'est
Michel Sapin le ministre du Travail qui
sera présent pour lui répondre voilà ces
questions d'actualité commence donc je
vous laisse les suivre en direct on se
retrouve ensuite ici pour refaire
ensemble la séance avec nos invités des
sénateur des ministres à tout à l'heure
la question ainsi que le ministre le ou
la ministre pour sa réponse dispose de 2
minutes 30 la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane Mazard pour le groupe
RDSE merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à madame la garde des
saau ministre de la
Justice madame la ministre la réalité
d'un état de droit se mesure au degré de
libre accès à la justice de ses citoyens
et notamment des plus démunis d'entre
eux avec les membres de mon groupe nous
n'avons cessé de dénoncer la situation
désastreuse de l'aide juridictionnelle
victime de un sous-financement
chronique nous avons combattu en 2011 la
création de la contribution pour l'aide
juridique de 35 € qui touche l'immense
majorité des justiciables et restreint
d'autant leur accès à la
justice madame la garde des saau vous
aviez annoncé peu de temps après votre
prise de fonction votre souhait
d'abroger cette contribution et de
trouver des modes de financement
pérennes et juste pour l'aide
juridictionnelle mais malheureusement
les derniers arbitrages du gouvernement
ne vont pas dans en ce sens et nous
inquiète il ressort en effet du projet
de loi de
finances pour 2014 que la suppression de
cette contribution d'un rendement de 60
millions d'euros s'accompagnerait d'une
économie supplémentaire de 32 millions
d'euros sur le budget de l'accès au
droit don 15 millions d'euros
ponctionnés sur les avocats au travers
une diminution pouvant aller jusqu'à
près de 12 % de leur unité de valeur ce
projet a déjà été rejeté par le Conseil
national de l'aide J
et par le Conseil national des barreaux
de même qu'il suscite de fortes réserves
de la part de la Commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme et
j'ajoute qu'une grève des audiences aura
lieu demain dans nombre de départements
si en outre la Chancellerie persister
dans l'idée d'une taxation sur le
chiffre d'affaires de ceux qui assument
le poids réel de l'aide juridictionnelle
vous généreriez alors face à une
injustice inacceptable des réactions
légitimes encore plus fortes l'enjeu
dépasse le très loin les seuls
professionnels du droit l'enjeu et vous
le savez madame la ministre c'est
l'accès de la justice pour tous et le
droit élémentaire de tous citoyens
d'être tout simplement
défendu j'ajoute qu'actuellement cette
question de l'aide juridictionnelle fait
l'objet de nombreuses réflexions je
pense par exemple aux travaux de nos
collègues sénateurs Sophie joissin et
Jacques mzard alors pourquoi ne pas
attendre leur conclusion mais surtout
madame la ministre mesurez-vous bien les
conséquences d'une telle décision pour
pouvez-vous nous rassurer sur vos
intentions de permettre à la justice
d'être accessible à tous s'agit-il
encore madame la ministre de l'une des
priorités du
gouvernement merci la parole est à
Madame Christiane tobira gardz saut
ministre de la Justice monsieur le
Président Mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Mazar je connais l'engagement
de votre groupe parlementaire sur cette
question depuis de nombreuses années
cela donne d'autant plus de poids à
votre question la l'aide
juridictionnelle relève d'une politique
de l'État une politique publique qui
consiste à garantir au plus démunis
l'accès au juges et l'accès à l'avocat
vous savez que cette aide
juridictionnelle concerne les
justiciables qui ont bénéficie les
juridiction qui la gère et les avocats
qui accomplissent en réalité une mission
de service public et qui sont rémunérés
pour cette mission j'en conviens
absolument pas à la hauteur de la
qualité de la mission assurée pour ce
qui concerne les justiciables nous
devons veiller aux intérêts de chacune
de ces trois parties pour ce qui
concerne les justiciables je me suis
engagé effectivement l'année dernière à
supprimer le thbre de 35 € de 35 € qui
entravait pour les plus démunis l'accès
au juges et cette parole est tenue
puisque le gouvernement s'y était engagé
lui-même c'est un engagement du
Président de la République et le
gouvernement a donc abonder le budget du
ministère de la Justice des 60 millions
d'euros qui permettent en compensation
d'abroger ce timbre de 35 € puisque ce
timbre rapportait à l'aide
juridictionnelle 65 55 millions d'euros
le gouvernement bande 60 millions
d'euros ce qui veut dire que le
jusriciable n'a plus d'entrave dans
l'accès au juges mais il n'a plus
d'entrave il n'a pas d'entrave à l'accès
à l'avocat parce que nous n'avons
modifié aucun critère d'accès ni le
plafond de ressources ni les procédure
cependant effectivement la démodulation
de l'unité de valeur qui est une
égalisation de cette unité de valeur sur
l'ensemble du territoire pénalise
certains barreaux la question de fond
est celle de la pérenisation de l'aide
juridictionnelle et depuis plusieurs
mois j'ai travaillé avec la profession
nous avons essayé de trouver les moyens
les ressources nécessaire pour
consolider pérenniser cette aide
juridictionnelle ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui concerne la rémunération des
avocats cette rémunération n'a pas
augmenté depuis plusieurs années mais je
vous rappelle néanmoins que l'année
dernière ce gouvernement avait augmenté
de 16 % l'enveloppe de l'aide
juridictionnelle nous allons construire
une une aide juridictionnelle durable
avec la profession nous allons le faire
parce que la profession manifeste son
désir de travailler à construire ce
dispositif durable parce que c'est une
condition pour assurer l'accès à la
justice aujourd'hui nous avons des
contentieux de masse qui concerern les
plus démunis qui ne sont pas couverts
par l'Aide Juridictionnelle nous voulons
mettre un terme à cette injustice et
nous allons le faire avec la profession
avec l'aide de vos travaux parce
qu'évidemment le rapport mesar joissin
va apporter
des éléments de réflexion qui vont
s'ajouter au rapport de de l'inspection
générale que j'ai chargé d'évaluer cette
politique publique merci la parole à
Monsieur Alain Milon pour le groupe UMP
oui monsieur le Président
merci mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Madame la Ministre
chargée de la Famille la loi madame la
ministre assure au Comité consultatif
national d'éthique créé en
1983 une plue disciplinarité et un
pluralisme qui permet de croiser les
regards et les opinions sur chaque
question nous renseigne le site de cette
instance précisant que parmi les 39
membres nommés pour 4 ans 5 les têes en
raison de leur appartenance aux
principales famille philosophique et
spirituel ne dépendant d'aucune autorité
de tutelle situation harissime le CCNE
rend ses avis en totale indépendance
comment y croire encore après le
renouvellement quelque peu précipité de
de ses membres à l'approche des états
généraux de la bioéthique organisée par
le CCNE à la veille d'importants débats
parlementaire susceptible de modifier la
législation en vigueur en matière de PMA
en matière de fin de vie le le président
de la République en charge de nommer les
représentants des courants de pensées au
sein de ce CCNE a décidé que les
représentants officiels des religions
concernées seront remplacés par des
laïques appartenantes à la religion
considéré une telle exclusion dans son
principe est choquante à divers titres
elle modifie le fondement de la
composition du Comité national d'éthique
concernant les représentants des
principales familles de pensée dans
notre pays et porte atteinte au
pluralisme de ses membres institué par
un décret du Président de la République
François mitteran en 1983 et confirmé
dès la première loi de la dès la
première loi de bioéthique en 1994
elle laisse supposer un nouveau concept
de la laïcité qui au lieu d'intégrer les
courants religieux à travers leurs
représentants hiérarchiqu les rejette de
la plus haute instance éthique nationale
dont on sait que ces avis se limitent à
n'être que consultatifs elle laisse
interpréter la volonté d'une
instrumentalisation politique du CCNE
qui pourrait perdre ainsi toute ou
partie de son indépendance et par voie
de conséquence sa crédibilité auprès des
scientifiques
et plus largement auprès de notre
société elle fait voler en éclat le
modèle du Comité national d'éthique
français le premier du genre qui a été
repris par une trentaine de pays ce qui
ne peut que ternir son image pérenisé
depuis 30 ans n'est-ce pas Madame la
Ministre jouer avec la loi la biaisé que
d'agir ainsi vous qui êtes les
turiférraires autoprogrammés de la
diversité en voilà une que vous
n'acceptez pas au nom d'un laïcisme
absolu certainement s'il vous plaît la
questionouver vous le savez tous sur les
grands sujets sociéau dont nous avons et
aurons à débattre dans notre pays dans
cet hémicycle même je ne peux cependant
accepter ce qui peut apparaître nêtre
qu'une manipulation pour imposer sans
partage l'exliquez-vous autrement merci
la parole à Madame Dominique Bertinotti
ministre chargé de la
famille monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieurs le
sénateur je suis un petit peu étonné
quand on connaît vos positions le ton
que vous avez utilisé pour poser cette
question sur le comité
consultatif mais je tiens je tiens à
rappeler vous-même vous en conviendrez
nous nous nous serons d'accord vous
l'avez dit le le Comité consultatif
national d'éthique a été constitué en
1983 et vous avez raison de vous
féliciter que la France est été le
premier pays à créer un Comité
consultatif national d'éthique pour les
sciences de la vie et de la santé je
vous rappelle que les règles de
composition ont très peu changé depuis
1983 qu'elles ont évolué par la loi du 6
août
2004 voté sur le gouvernement de
Jean-Pierre rafarin et que l'article R
14123 du code de la santé publique
dispose que le comité est renouvelé par
moitié tous les 2 ans je rappelle aussi
que le Président de la République nomme
le président du CCNE pour une période de
2 ans renouvelable oui
mais c'est important de rappeler les
choses car je vais vous démontrer dans
un instant qu'il n'y a aucune façon de
contrevenir à des règles qui sont
édictés et que nous respectons je tiens
à dire et vous l'avez dit très
clairement que par parmi les 39 membres
C appartiennent aux principales famille
philosophique et spirituelle et sont
nommés par le Président de la République
tel est le contenu de la loi le
gouvernement a agi donc en conformité
avec ses règles dès 83 les textes
prévoient que le président nomme des
personnalités appartenant et je recite
aux principales familles philosophique
et spirituel et que le président actuel
du CCNE le professeur hisen dit lui-même
que l'histoire du CCNE n'a pas toujours
compté de religieux en son sein et qu'il
y a eu des phases différentes en la
matière donc on peut considérer que la
nomination des de ces cinq
personnalités constitue un retour à
l'esprit même du comité tel qu'il a été
créé en
1983 c'est-à-dire avoir vocation
à ouvrir ses portes aux différents
courants de pensées philosophique et
religieux mais porté effectivement par
des personnalités laïqu enfin pour
conclure je voudrais juste vous dire
comment contester la la la compétence et
l'indépendance d'esprit de Madame
carbonier burcart historienne et maître
de conférence honoraire de l'histoire du
christianisme comment contester je finis
juste là-dessus la personnalité de
Lionel nakach ou de Frédéric Vorms merci
Madame la
Ministre la parole est à Madame
Catherine main de sailli pour le groupe
udi UC monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'éducation nationale vous
avez engagé une réforme des rythmes
scolaires dont le principe n'a jamais
été remis en cause mais qui nécessité
une préparation suffisante et
approfondie malheureusement un mois
après la rentrée des classes la plus
grande confusion règne les élus locaux
font beaucoup d'efforts dans l'intérêt
de nos enfants mais nombreus sont ceux
qui ne voient toujours pas de réponses
concrète et pertinent aux carences de
cette réforme interpellerz tous les
jours nous ne pouvons qu'être inquiets
je vous avais pourtant alerté dès le 25
janvier lors d'une même séance de
question contre un passage en force qui
risquait d'être contreproductif je vous
avais engagé à dialoguer avec tous les
partenaires de l'école et d'abord avec
les élus locaux à l'UDI nous considérons
que ce sujet trop important pour être
instrumentaliser l'enjeu est notre
capacité à nous
réformer encore faut-il que ce soit pas
fait dans la précipitation et
l'impréparation c'est pourquoi je vous
demande monsieur le ministre de faire de
l'année scolaire 2013-24 une année
pleine et entière
d'expérimentation ce qui permettrait
d'intégrer les retours d'expérience de
façon appliqué à la rentrée scolaire
2015 une réforme largement améliorée à
tout point de vue nous avions formulé
cette demande lors du projet deoie de
refondation de l'école avec ma collègue
Françoise ferra mes chers collègues tous
les jours nous sommes pris à témoin par
les élus de nos départements de mon côté
j'ai recueilli de nombreux témoignages
de bon sens pourquoi ne pas lancer une
consultation pour recueillir le point de
vue de chacun les sénateurs udiuc
souhaitent que son résultat fasse
l'objet d'un moment d'échange lors du
prochain congrès de l'AMF monsieur le
ministre vraiment vous ne réussirez pas
cette réforme sans y associer
profondément les élus êtes-vous prêt à
attendre leur voix êtes-vous prêt à
engager une concertation prolongée et un
travail approfondi avec les
collectivités locales du coup êtes-vous
d'accord pour sursoir à la date du 30
novembre afin de laisser le temps aux
élus de s'organiser ils doivent rendre
leurs copies en tout cas ceux qui n'ont
pas encore appliqué la réforme je vous
en prie
écoutez-les merci pour vous répondre
monsieur Vincent payon ministre
éducation
nationale merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice j'ai toujours un
grand plaisir à vous écouter donc ne
vous inquiétez pas la concertation elle
a commencé en 2010 car les
expérimentations dont vous parl vous les
avez expérimenté elles ont été
hasardeuses elles sont évaluées la
suppression de 60000 postes la
suppression de la formation des
enseignants je viens de quand nous avons
ouvert la première école supérieure du
professorat et l'éducation et
l'instauration de la semaine de 4 jours
enlever 2 heures de cours à tous les
enfants du primaire de France ça é votre
expérimentation au point que au point
que un an après cette sattise le Premier
ministre Xavier D'cos de l'éducation
nationale avant Châtel a reconnu
lui-même qu'il fallait revenir sur cette
erreur vous avez alors dès 2010 commencé
une concertation les groupes ont été
consultés l'Academie l'Académie de
médecine s'est exprimé une conférence
nationale dans laquelle le Parlement a à
nouveau été consulté a eu lieu en 2011
sous la responsabilité de Monsieur
Chatel et les conclusions ont été à
l'unanimité il faut revenir à la semaine
de 4 jours et demi est-ce que toutes ces
concertations doivent rester dans un
tiroir ou est-ce qu'à un moment quatre
concertations doivent se traduire dans
une action lorsqu'il s'agit de l'intérêt
des élèves de ce pays cette réforme que
nous faisons c'est pour réparer ce que
vous avez défit et pour faire ce que
vous n'avez pas eu le courage de
faire la concertation que vous demandez
mais enfin elle a lieu depuis un an et
demi que nous sommes là le temps que
vous souhaitez il vous a été accordé par
le Président de la République personne
n'était obligé de passer en 2013 le
temps que vous demandez jusqu fin
novembre il est évidemment accepté donc
une fois de plus vous jouez sur les
peurs vous ne jouez pas sur la
vous ne dites pas la réalité des choses
parce que au fond du fond vous ne voulez
pas de cette réforme pas plus que vous
ne vouliez de la formation des
enseignants pas plus que vous vouliz
faire de l'école une priorité nous notre
responsabilité c'est de faire en sorte
que les enfants de France aient un
meilleur temps scolaire pour apprendre à
lire écrire compter c'est le mercredi
matin et c'est offert à tous les enfants
c'est qu'ils aient un meilleur temps P
éducatif plus de justice c'est ce que
nous faisons par l'organisation des
temps périscolaires tout cela se fait
dans la concertation sur le terrain
puisque ce sont des projets éducatifs de
territoire qui doivent être construits
alors vous ne pouvez pas dire le
contraire de ce qui se passe la
concertation est engagée là où cela
réussit dans l'immense majorité des cas
c'est précisément parce que la
concertation a eu lieu mais nous avons
noté que certains ne veulent pas se
concerter c'est vous votre mauvaise
volonté est visible elle pénalise des
enfants et j'ai même vu le président
d'un parti politique l'UMP vouloir faire
des orphelins de 15h30 en ne respectant
pas les règles de la République merci la
parole est à Madame Françoise Cartron
pour le groupe
socialiste monsieur le Président ma
question s'adriste à mon tour à monsieur
le ministre de l'éducation
nationale forme des rythmes scolaires
occupe l'actualité de ces derniers jours
avec ses excès ses approximation et ses
contre vérité par opportunisme politique
l'opposition est vant debout contre une
réforme qu'elle appelé hier de ses vœux
rappelons-nous en 2011 la consultation
initiée par Monsieur chattel alors
ministre de l'éducation nationale
concluer à l'unanimité il faut changer
les rythmes c'est-à-dire alléger les
temps de l'enfant et rapidement parce
que les rythmes d'apprentissage dans
notre pays sont insoutenables journée la
plus longue année la plus courte deux
anomalies préjudiciables en premier lieu
pour les enfants les plus fragiles vous
avez à votre tour monsieur le ministre
lancé une nouvelle consultation
parvenant au même conclusion approuvé
par tous les participants le consensus
est là je rappelle qu'en plus de mieux
répartir le temps scolaire cette réforme
permet d'offrir à tous les élèves un
accès élargi aux activités périscolaires
les disparités sociales à la matière
étant à ce jour criante alors que plus
d'une commune sur 5 met en œuvre la
réforme depuis la rentrée il me paraît
utile de rappeler que pour la majorité
d'entre elles cela se passe bien vous
avez d'ailleurs pu le constater sur le
terrain monsieur le ministre toutefois
et cela a toujours été dit cette réforme
est difficile parce qu'elle induit parce
qu'elle induit une évolution des
pratiques de la pédagogie des relations
de l'école avec les autres acteurs
éducatifs il est vrai néanmoins
qu'aujourd'hui un certain nombre
d'interrogations existent des
questionnements légitimes avec des
réponses qui ici ou là
on pu manqu de clarté ou favoriser le
doute c'est pourquoi j'ai souhaité vous
interroger monsieur le ministre quant à
la mise en place des rythmes à la
rentrée 2014 premièrement quelle date
limite fixez-vous aux communes afin
qu'elles rendent leurs copies auazen
dans les projets éducatifs territoriaux
afin de rassurer les maires
pourriez-vous rappeler à quel
financement ils peuvent prétendre et
confirmer que l'engagement de la CAF ne
se substitue pas au fond d'amorçage
enfin pour les communes qui appliquent
déjà les nouveaux rythmes la question se
pose cette réforme nécessite un effort
financier des
collectivités je le crois un
accompagnement pérennisé sur 2014
pourraé apparaître comme un
encouragement et je le dis à Madame
Maurine de sailli ce n'est pas parce que
les choses sont difficiles que nous
n'osons pas c'est parce que nous n'osons
pas qu'elles sont difficiles
merci monsieur le ministre brièvement si
possible d'abord vous avez raison de
rappeler madame la sénatrice l'essentiel
c'est-à-dire quand même le meilleur
temps scolaire qu'on doit offrir aux
enfants et souvent il est perdu de vue
parce qu'il n'est pas la première
préoccupation il est meilleur pour
apprendre à lire écrire compté de le
faire à 9h30 le matin qu'à 16h15 le
reste de la semaine et dans le déclin
scolaire des enfants cette question est
centrale elle a été soulevé d'ailleurs
par tous les spécialistes et même les
parlementaires depuis des années deuxème
temps dans les accueils périscolaires a
que 20 % des enfants qui sont accueillis
aujourd'hui en France avec des
inégalités allant de 1 à 10 et ce temps
périscolaire est toujours payant la
caisse d'allocation familiale a modifié
sa convention d'objectif pour permettre
qu'il soit aujourd'hui gratuit et le
président de la République a accordé un
fond qui permet de subventionner les
collectivités locales de telle sorte
qu'ell puissent rendre ses activités
gratuites cela permettra de faire que ce
ne soit plus 20 % des enfants mais 80 %
des enfants qui en profitent c'est donc
une bonne réforme scolaire c'est une
bonne réforme forme éducatif et c'est en
plus une réforme de justice c'est
peut-être pour cela que la droite ne la
soutient pas comme elle le devrait
madame sur les trois questions que vous
avez posé les réponses sont très
nettement les suivantes et ça permettra
de corriger toutes les approximations
qui ont été pu qui ont pu être faites
d'une part les 54 € de la knaf pérénisé
déjà pour 3 ans ne se substittu en rien
aux 50 € et au 40 € du fond d'amorçage
dont nous aurons à voir dans une
discussion avec l'Association des maires
de France et les élus locaux la
pérénisation pour les temps à venir et
donc c'est bien 140 ou 145 € pour les
collectivités éligibles à la DSU ou la
DSR comme mot de Jean-François Copé qui
était disponible par enfant cette année
c'est-à-dire l'estimation exacte faite
par le président de l'AMF lui-même
deuxièmement madame la sénatrice je ne
sais pas quelle rumeur une nouvelle fois
court mais c'est le rôle de l'école de
remplacer l'opinion par le savoir j'ai
donné instruction aux daen j'ai donné
instruction aux daen qu'il n'y ait pas
de temps limitatif pour les communes qui
doivent rendre leur projet de territoire
et on verra bien alors quelle est la
bonne volonté de ceux qui de mois en
mois après d'année en année repousse en
permanence l'intérêt des enfants mais je
le dis nettement ce que nous voulons
c'est la concertation nous sommes au
côté des élus nous les accompagnons et
il y a aucune date impérative pour
remettre ces projets simplement si on
veut que les familles et les
informations que les présidents de
conseil généraux puissent organiser les
transports il y a 3 mois de consultation
officielle et je crois qu'il serait
préférable de commencer le plus tôt
possible et c'est ce que je demande aux
élus merci monsieur le ministre vous
avez é puisé votre temps troisièmement
sur les financements pour l'année 2014
il est bien entendu que nous continuons
la discussion et qu'il n'y a pas
d'inquiétude à avoir très bien merci la
parole à Madame Esther bembassa pour le
groupe
écologiste monsieur le Président chers
collègues et ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
monsieur le ministre le tribunal de
grande instance de Paris a rendu hier sa
décision dans l'affaire opposant à
l'état et au ministère de l'Intérieur 1
plignant dénonçant des contrôles de
police au Fiè ils ont été déboutés il ne
nous n'appartient bien sûr pas de
commenter une décision de justice cela
nous oblige-t-il pour autant à garder
ici le silence car ce qui est en cause
en l'occurrence est bien l'article
78- 2 du code de procédure pénale un
article qui en l'état r rend possible le
contrôle au facièise vous déclariez il y
a peu que je vous cite le contrôle au
fciè doit cesser c'est du racisme et
forcé de reconnaître que euh vous n'en
êtes pas resté au stade des promesses le
code de déontologie de la police a été
modifié pour interdire par exemple le
tutoiement de même toute personne
s'estimant victime d'un comportement
susceptible de mettre en cause des
agents affectés dans un service de la
police nationale peut désormais le faire
directement savoir en ligne à
l'Inspection générale de la police
nationale ces mesures sont loin d'être
veines reste que la décision rendue hier
nous rappelle qu'il est temps pour nous
législateurs d'amender la loi vous le
savez monsieur le ministre je milite
pour la délivrance de réépicé lors des
contrôles d'identité j'ai déposé au nom
du groupe écologiste une PPL à cette fin
il y a 2 ans le défenseur des droits
dans son rapport sur la question le
préconise également nos syndicats de
police s'y opposent redoutant qu'une
telle mesure bride leur liberté d'AC
les polices d'autres pays pourtant
l'appliquent avec des résultats positifs
pourquoi ne pas tenter une
expérimentation dans des localités
volontaire pour en tester l'efficacité à
vrai dire toute mesures concrètees
susceptible d'aider à limiter la
multiplication des contrôles inutiles
serait la bienvenue port du matricule
mini caméra portable formation de la
police pouvez-vous nous dire monsieur le
ministre quel calendrier vous envisagez
pour la mise en place
au moins de telles mesur même si le
répic paraît à beaucoup et notamment aux
personnes contrôl abusivement comme le
plus sûr moyen d'atteindre notre
objectif merci merci Monsieur Manuel
Vals ministre
l'intérieur monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la
sénatrice la relation entre les forces
de l'ordre et les citoyens do reposer
évidemment sur de la confiance sur de la
considération sur des respects moi je
veux rendre hommage bien sûr au travail
des forces de l'ordre policiers et
gendarmes qui complissent leur mission
souvent dans des conditions difficiles
je constate d'ailleurs contrairement à
ce que l'on dit souvent que nos
concitoyens soutiennent de manière très
importante massive même ces deux
institutions pour autant il faut
retrouver aussi au moins dans un certain
nombre de territoires de quartiers les
conditions de cette confiance nous
n'avons pas fait le choix du récipic
vous avez raison il y a des
expérimentations à l'étranger mais nous
avons considéré que elle n'était pas
suffisamment efficace et qu'elle
pourrait aussi être considérée par les
forces de l'ordre comme un élément de
défiance mais nous avons décidé surtout
d'engager des chantiers très importants
vous l'avez dit la refondte du code de
déontologie cela n'avait pas été fait
depuis 1986 qui est désormais commun à
la police et à la gendarmerie dans ce
code d'odontologie il y a une grande
partie qui est consacrée au contrôle
d'identité et au palpations sur les
recommandation du Défenseur des droits
le code est en train d'être examiné par
le Conseil d'État il pourra être mis je
l'espère très vite en œuvre un numéro
d'identification le matricule sur les
uniformes et les brassards des policiers
et les gendarmes sera appliqué à partir
de la fin de l'année les marchés
d'habillement sont en cours et puis très
important nous avons procédé une réforme
très importante de l'inspection générale
de la police nationale en fondant l'IGPN
avec l'inspection générale des services
de la préfecture de police de Paris avec
une plateforme internet qui permet
depuis le début du mois de septembre à
tous les citoyens avec un certain nombre
de règles qui encadre bien sûr cette
procédure de saisir la police des
polices s'il y avait les problèmes que
vous évoquez qui existe bien évidemment
voilà pour le reste c'est la loi c'est
la loi qui s'applique s'il y a des disc
discrimination du racisme des contrôles
qui ne se font pas dans le cadre légal
l'IGPN la loi sont là pour sanctionner
ce qui ne respecteraiit pas les règles
de la République moi je pense que c'est
le rôle du gouvernement de la
représentation parlementaire bien sûr
c'est de faire confiance aux forces de
l'ordre qui sont parmi les institutions
les plus contrôlées les plus surveillées
de notre pays elles agissent encore une
fois dans des conditions difficiles
elles doivent construire en permanence
cette relation de confiance avec la
population et dans le cadre des zones de
sécurité prioritaire avec mon collègue
François lami nous avons considéré
cétait une priorité la relation avec la
population comme cela se fait souvent
les policiers et les gendarmes doivent
aller devant la population c'est comme
ça que nous construirons cette relation
de confiance et que nous apporterons
aussi notre soutien aux forces de
l'ordre merci la parole est à madame la
Présidente Annie David pour le groupe
communiste républicain et
citoyen merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse au ministre du
Travail il aura suffi qu'une grande
enseigne de distribution obtienne la
condamnation d'une entreprise
concurrente qui ouvrait le dimanche en
toute illégalité faut-il le rappeler
pour que votre gouvernement décide
d'organiser un comité interministériel
sur la question du travail dominical et
que dans la Foulet vous chargiez d'une
mission un ancien grand patron connu à
plusieurs titres et notamment pour avoir
déjà participé à l'élaboration d'un
rapport du Conseil économique et social
le rapport salto dont d'ailleurs s'est
inspiré LEP Malié pour multiplier les
dérogations au repos dominical dans la
loi que nous avons ensemble à gauche ici
au Sénat combattu comme vous je suis
avec mes collègues du groupe communiste
républicain et citoyens attentive à la
situation des salariés qui travaillent
aujourd'hui le dimanche comme vous je ne
peux me me réjouir que des salariés
parce que leurs salaires sont trop bas
ou qu'ils travaillent dans la précarité
soit contraint pour subvenir au besoins
de leur famille de travailler le
dimanche au risque même de fragiliser
ses ces liens familiaux mais aussi
amicaux ou encore associatifs comme vous
aussi je ne peux me résoudre à ce que
l'on accepte que des étudiants soit
contraint de travailler le weekend et
parfois les soirs pour financer leurs
études souvent au détriment de leur
réussite il y a là d'ailleurs mes chers
collègues une inégalité d'accès au
savoir qui est intolérable comme vous je
l'espère je suis convaincu que le
travail du dimanche n'est ni la solution
à la faiblesse des salaires ni à la
détresse des milliers d'étudiants
étudiants qui revendiquent depuis des
années et nous y sommes favorables une
allocation d'études leur permettant
d'être autonome et d'étudier sereinement
d'ailleurs une majorité de gauche au
Sénat a en 2011 adopté la proposition de
loi que j'ai déposé pour renforcer le
droit au repos dominical convaincu que
nos concitoyennes et concitoyens ont
besoin de disposer de temps libérés
permettant les retrouvaills familiales
amicales ou associatives un temps
qu'André Henri ancien ministre
socialiste du temps libre qualifié cet
été je cite de temps choisis qui reste
toujours une idée neuve tout à l'opposé
en somme de cette société où le tout
marchand l'emporte toujours sur l'humain
voulons-nous une société où l'argent
prime et opprime les plus faibles ou une
société d'émancipation des femmes et des
hommes créateurs de richesse pour les
sénatrices et sénateur communistes
républicains et citoyens le choix est
clair celui d'une société émancipat
et offrant às jeunes un avenir de
progrès monsieur le ministre avez-vous
renoncé avec le gouvernement auquel vous
appartenez à ce modèle de société
émancipatrice merci Monsieur Michel
Sapin ministre du Travail de l'Emploi de
la Formation professionnelle du dialogue
social merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices madame la Présidente vous
m'interrogez sur la question du repos
dominical qui est un principe ancien et
qui n'est pas issu de n'importe quoi qui
est issu de ces combats d'hommes et de
femmes qui il y a un siècle ou un peu
plus travaillit 7 jours sur 7 sans qu'il
y ait d'arrêt travaillait parfois jour
et nuit sans qu'il y ait de règles pour
fixer ce qui doit être naturellement le
rôle de la loi les limites à une loi qui
était la loi de la gungle le
gouvernement est attaché au maintien du
principe du repos dominicain
nous c'est Dominic ailleurs ce sera un
samedi ailleurs ce sera un vendredi mais
il n'y a pas un pays en Europe qui dise
7 jours sur 7 on travaille et on a le
droit de travailler il y a toujours un
jour de repos dans la semaine nous y
tenons deè chose mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs si je devais vous demander
votre avis je pense que j'aurais du mal
à obtenir un avis
convergent madame la Présidente ce que
je constate ce que vous constatez c'est
d'abord une chose c'est beaucoup en
région parisienne que le problème est
posé parce qu'en région parisienne c'est
vrai qu'il y a aussi des conditions
peut-être faut-il lutter ensemble contre
ces conditions particulières lorsque
vous avez passé 1h30 le matin en
transport 1h30 le soir en transport il
vous reste peu de temps contrairement à
ce qui peut se passer dans l'isè ou
argent en surcreuse pour faire vos
propres courses deuxième chose deuxème
chose il y a un énorme désordre
aujourd'hui ce désordre il a été créé
par une loi la loi MAEt de 2009 qui
croyait-il vous permettrait d'ouvrir
mieux mais il ouvre sans ouvrir il ouvre
dans le désordre et aujourd'hui ce que
nous voyons ce sont des décisions de
justice qui constatent le caractère
totalement inapplicable de manière
ordonné d'une loi qui est une mauvaise
loi une mauvaise législation il nous
faut remettre de l'ordre dans un
désordre qui a été créé par une loi
votée par cette partieelà de l'hémicycle
oui nous allons remettre de l'ordre et
nous allons le faire faire et nous
allons le faire par la concertation nous
avons demandé à une personnalité de
travailler mais de travailler vite en
l'espace de 2 mois pour entendre les
différents partenaires syndicaux
patronaux locaux et trouver une solution
proposer une solution ensuite le
gouvernement prendra sa responsabilité
si le Parlement doit être saisi il le
sera et je pense que c'est par la
concertation aussi que nous ferons en
sorte qu'une des plus graves inégalités
soit il y a des salariés qui travaillent
le dimanche et qui sont payés double et
il y a les mêmes salariés dans d'utres
entreprises qui travaillent le dimanche
et qui sont payé comme le reste du temps
là aussi y a une égalité contre laquelle
nous lutterons merci la parole à
Monsieur François gridier pour le groupe
ma question s'adressa à Monsieur le
Premier Ministre il est absent comme
Monsieur montebour courage Fillon il y a
de semaines à matigon il a signé avec le
président de la Région Lorine le pacte
Laurin un contrat illégal parce que non
approuvé par le Conseil Régional un
contrat banal avec 150 millions d'euros
cela représente seulement 4 % des 3
milliards et demi annoncés 5 jours plus
tôt par le Président de la République
pour une nouvelle France industrielle 4
% c'est la part de la laoren dans la
population française c'est le droit
commun pas un € de plus pour la laorine
il n'y a que l'emballage qui change il a
mise en scène un non événement l'acte 2
de cette pièce joué avec plus de BRI
encore la semaine dernière à florenge
c'est la réconciliation entre le
Président de la République et le leader
charismatique de la CFDT il mérite de
César ou de Oscars ou de molièr
réconciliation concertée et théâtrale
Édouard Martin virile nous nous sommes
expliqués d'homme à homme François
Hollande touchant nous nous sommes
parlés les yeux dans les yeux pourtant
un an après sa trahison et la fermeture
des haut fourneaux de Florange le
président n'a toujours pas expliqué son
incompréhensible refus du plan de
reprise parfaitement viable de Bernard
serin avec 500 millions d'euros sur la
table et qu'a-t-il proposé à la place
des haut fourneaux et des 600
suppressions d'emploi un
gadget un plateforme de recherche
publique pour 20 millions d'euros auquel
pourrait sous condition s'ajouter 30
millions d'euros à partir de 2015 il a
dit que dans ce nouveau centre nous
trouverons demain les brevets qui
permettront après-demain de rebâtir une
nouvelle sidérurgie lorraine pour 20
millions d'euros vous payez des
bâtiments pas les équipements et encore
moins les chercheurs c'est ridicule il
existe déjà 10 km de la mier lemes
Arcelor reserche c'est la NASA de la
sidérurgie le plus important centre de
recherche sidérurgique au monde il vaut
des milliards d'euros il emploie 800
personnes un budget annuel de plus de
100 millions d'euros cette recherche
privé est déjà fédéré à la recherche
publique en Lorine au sein de l't du
pôle de compétitivité alors 50 millions
d'euros sur l'IRT aurait pu avoir un
sens alors trois questions pourquoi
avez-vous il y a un an refusé le plan de
reprise des haut fourneau deuxièmement
croyez-vous sincèrement qu'on va
découvrir dans ce centre gadget ce que
l'on n'aurait pas découvert dans les
centres de recherche qui existe déjà et
troisièmement croyez-vous sérieusement
que vous pouvez contraindre quiconque à
exploiter en laorine desbrevé parce
qu'ils auraient été trouvés en laorine
merci Madame jeuneviève fouriso ministre
d'enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur François grodidier nous allons
parler Recherche et Innovation et emploi
créé grâce à la recherche à l'innovation
il est donc légitime que ce soit la
ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche qui s'exprime au nom du
gouvernement alors la Lorine est une
région industrielle je pourrais presque
dire était une région industrielle elle
a gardé sa culture industrielle mais
malheureusement son industrie a été
fragilisée par le manque
d'investissement au cours de la dernière
décennie dans l'innovation née de la
recherche publique c'est la région qui a
été le plus fragilisée au cours de ces
10 dernières années et qui a perdu le
plus d'empo industriel je rappelle qu'au
niveau national nous en avons perdu
750000 par manque de montée en gamme et
par manque d'investissement àont
l'investissement comme privé dans la
recherche public comme privé monsieur
grodidier se devait donc d'être relancé
et les sénateurs Gisel prince et
jean-marcini que je salue connaissent
bien la situation aussi bien si ce n'est
mieux que vous le président de la
République François Hollande et le
Premier ministre Jean-Marc donc pris
toute le responsabilité au côté de leurs
deux ministres
opérationnels AR montebour ministre
ministre du redressement productif et
moi-même pour l'enseignement supérieur
et la recherche car il s'agit bien de
formation et d'investissement dans la
recherche un plan ambitieux de recherche
publique et privée c'est démodé et c'est
terminé l'époque où on opposait
recherche publique et privée on
travaille ensemble maintenant chacun
dans sa mission un grand plan de plus de
300 millions d'euros a été lancé avec
plusieurs volets un volet qui
effectivement est un sous-ensemble du
centre de recherche arsital et qui
travaille avec les laboratoires publics
et en particulier avec la plateforme du
CEATEC qui existe déjà avec succès dans
si villes en France dans si métropoles
il y a un autre projet qui élargit le
projet existant le projet LCE qui veut
fournir effectivement des métaux qui est
utille pour la métallurgie et qui réduit
l'impact carbone et vous devriez le
connaître je crois c'est la suite du
projet hulcos que vous avez un peu raté
il y a il y a
également il y a également une grande
plateforme technologique qui va
rassembler tout cela et tout cela est
convenu dans un grand accord signé entre
la Région et l'État je rappelle que ces
300 millions d'euros vont constituer un
levier de 1 milliard et demi d'euros
d'investissement publics et privés et
que de votre côté Nicolas Sarkozi qui
s'est rendu une seule fois contrairement
à ses promesses en Lorine s'était engagé
en faveur d'un investissement de 17
million d'euros dont pas 1 € n'a été
investi nous n'avons pas de leçon à
recevoir et nous nous jouons l'avenir de
la Lorine un avenir industriel un avenir
d'une industrie porteuse et pas d'une
industrie comme celle que vous avez
condamné merci la parole est à Madame
Bernadette bourzet pour le groupe
socialiste merci monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Agriculture
de l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt
monsieur le ministre vous avez
accompagné hier le président de la
République à Cournon d'Auvergne au
Sommet de l'élevage grand rendez-vous
européen des professionnels et l'une des
plus belles vitrine de la diversité de
notre agriculture de ses productions et
de ses territoires votre déplacement
correspondait à un moment clé où l'État
doit prendre des décisions quant à la
mise en œuvre de la PAC en France
nouvelle étape après les avancées
notables que vous avez obtenu au niveau
européen car nous le savons bien c'est
grâce aux efforts du Président de la
République et au vôtres que nous avons
pu sauvegarder l'essentiel à savoir un
accord européen garantissant globalement
le budget agricole de la France car la
tendance du gouvernement précédent était
plutôt de le laisser aller à la baisse
et tout cela en amorçant une nouvelle
approche de la PAC à travers les
paiements redistributifs le recouplage
des aides ou encore la mise en place du
verdissement certes si cette pâack n'est
pas révolutionnaire dans son
fonctionnement elle est néanmoins
novatrice dans les possibilité qu'elle
offre en permettant à chaque étatmembre
d'utiliser ses outils pour mettre en
œuvre sa politique agricole commune
c'est pourquoi sa transcription suscite
des attentes fortes en particulier chez
les éleveurs qui attendent avec ir aux
arbitrages en effet le secteur de
l'élevage traverse depuis plusieurs
années des difficultés structurelles
résultat de la dérégulation totale qui a
prévalu ces 10 dernières années
l'élevage a perdu en 10 ans de 15 à 25 %
de ses productions selon les secteurs et
c'est un constat que nous avons fait
avec la filière viande très récemment le
président de la République l'a rappelé
hier quand la production de l'élevage
recu c'est toute une filière qui
s'effondre et c'est la ruralité qui est
menacée dans ces fonds
depuis que vous êtes aux responsabilités
vous avez monsieur le ministre choisi d'
vrer pour une pâack plus juste dont la
priorité est une redistribution en
faveur de l'élevage et de l'emploi ce
dont je ne peux que me féliciter hier à
Cournon le président a montré sa
détermination à sauver l'élevage sans
pour autant déséquilibrer les autres
exploitations et à annoncer les
redistributions des aides de la PAC j'y
été et j'ai pu mesurer à la fin de son
intervention les applaudissements très
nourri d'un public qui à son arrivée
était pourtant grave car inquiet
pouvez-vous monsieur le ministre nous
indiquer les mesures qui permettront
d'améliorer la situation de l'élevage
sans pour autant mettre en danger les
autres secteurs agricoles je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Stéphane Lefol
ministre de l'Agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire de la
forêt monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice vous avez évoqué plusieurs
choses à la fois la négociation sur la
politique agricole commune et les
conséquences que nous le président de la
République en a tiré pour ce qui est de
l'application de cette politique
agricole commune à la France il y a un
an était engager un débat à l'échelle
européenne à la fois sur les
perspectives financières pour le budget
de l'Europe et vous l'avez rappelé ces
perspectives financières telles qu'elles
étaient prévues ne laissait pas augurer
grandchose de bon pour ce qui était du
budget de la politique agricole commune
la négociation qui a été conduite a
permis en particulier par l'implication
de la France et du président de la
République de garantir un budget pour
toute l'Europe d'ailleurs et toute la
politique agricole et faire en sorte
qu'on maintienne le budget pour ce qui
concerne la politique agricole française
après a été négocié durant une année une
politique agricole commune qui avait des
objectifs qui avaient été fixés avant
j'appelle et je rappelle à chacun
l'engagement qui avait été pris en 2003
à Luxembourg découplage total des aides
et convergence de la totalité des aides
vers la même aide à l'hectare partout en
Europe c'était ça l'objectif qui avait
été fixé par l'Europe et par les
gouvernements européens en 2003 à
Luxembourg dès 2008 dans les débats qui
ont eu lieu sur le bilan de santé
l'objectif qu'on s'est fixé c'était de
redresser cette ligne pour offrir des
perspectives en particulier sur la
question du couplage des aides pour
considérer que aider une production
c'était important en par particulier
pour l'élevage dans toutes les
négociations qui ont été conduites la
position de la France a été claire et
elle a entraîné de nombreux pays avec
elle le constat est celui-là à la fois
sur la question de la convergence et sur
la question du couplage nous sommes
passés d'une proposition de 10 % à 13 %
voire à 15 % puisque il sont intégrés
les protéagineux et les légumineuses
pour l'autonomie fourragère alors que je
le rappelle en 2003 c'était la
disparation ensuite sur le deuxè pilier
la négociation du président de la
République a permis de revaloriser les
aides du 2ème pilier l'objectif qui
avait été fixé pendant la campagne
présidentielle c'était de fixer des
priorités pour l'agriculture la première
le soutien à l'élevage et ici dans tous
ces bancs j'ai suffisamment participé à
des débats pour savoir ce qui était dit
sur la question de l'élevage priorité à
l'élevage prise en compte de l'emploi
dans l'agriculture et verdissement
puisque nous avons un défi à relever sur
économie et environnement le président
de la République a arbitré ces chosesl
ont été dites c'est 1 milliard d'euros
en fin de période qui sera transféré
vers l'élevage avec les paiements
redistributifs et les premiers hectares
c'est l'emploi qui sera pris en compte
en même temps que globalement sera
garanti l'équilibre de l'ensemble de
notre agriculture merci la parole à
Jean-François hussan pour le groupe
UNP ma question s'adresse à Monsieur
sapin
après le bug la fiabilité des chiffres
en question titrait un grand quotidien
régional il y a quelques jours en effet
après avoir annoncé une baisse de près
de 50000 chômeurs en août au sujet de
laquelle vous aviez déclaré réfuté toute
aberration statistique je vous cite vous
avez été contraint de reconnaître
l'erreur en constatant qu'elle était en
fait de
25000 vous êtes tellement obnubilé par
cette promesse présidentielle de voir la
courbe du chômage s'inverser avant la
fin 2013 qu'on vous sent paralysé pour
agir vos ondes de conviction aurait-elle
perturbé le réseau
SFR même si j'ai bien conscience que le
sujet est trop grave pour le traiter par
la
dérision trop grave pour accepter
l'impression que la réalité est voilée
trop grave pour souscrire à l'idée d'une
quelconque manipulation qui pourtant
doit-on croire aujourd'hui et que
doit-on croire car je veux rappeler que
depuis votre arrive au gouvernement les
chiffres du chômage n'ont cessé
d'augmenter au rythme de près de 30000
chômeurs supplémentaires chaque mois
comme moi vous savez que l'Unedic estime
que le chômage continuera d'augmenter en
2014 dans ce contexte où le combat pour
l'emploi doit être notre première
priorité nous ne voyons ni cap ni
stratégie ni cohérence d'action et les
Français sont inquiet et doute il doute
parce qu'il sentent chez vous comme un
aveu d'impuissance à attendre la fin
2013 pour voir un hypothétique
retournement de tendance de la courbe du
chômage il doute que vous mettiez en
place dans le secteur productif et avec
les entreprises de toute taille les
conditions et les dispositifs permettant
d'endiguer la montée du chômage il doute
encore quand il constate que vous avez
une nouvelle fois et aveuglément
privilégié les multiples hausses de tax
et d'impôt chez les particuliers comme
dans les entreprises entraavant par la
même leur capacité à
embaucher balloté de bugs en quak qui
créent doute et angoisse pour l'avenir
nos concitoyens ont plus que jamais
besoin que soit clairement affirmer un
cap pour l'emploi afin de retrouver
espoir et confiance monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous essayer de nous expliquer
sans invoquer la gestion d'hier comme
vous le faites si souvent quelle est
quelle est aujourd'hui quelle est
aujourd'hui la stratégie de votre
gouvernement pour combattre le chômage
et quels sont les conditions misise en
œuvre pour favoriser le maintien et la
création d'emploi notamment dans le
secteur productif emploi je le rappelle
non financé par la dette comme peuvent
l'être les emploisd merci Monsieur
Michel Sapin ministre du Travail de
l'Emploi merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices et je vous appelle monsieur
monsieur
sénateur sur un sujet aussi sérieux que
celui-ci je pense qu'il vaudrait mieux
éviter les effet de caricature ou de
polémiques inutiles ne serait-ce que
pardon de faire allusion à cela parce
que le chômage augmente chaque mois sauf
le mois d'août dernier j'y reviendrai
depuis 5 ans et qu'on peut comprendre
que les Français face à ce chômage qui
chaque mois frappe plus encore il y ait
une incrédulité une forme de d'absence
de confiance dans les politiques menées
par les uns et par les autres la
confiance revient monsieur le sénateur
et je vais vous dire pourquoi mais je
veux d'abord répondre à ce que vous avez
appelé vous-même le bug de SFR puis-je
vous faire laaveu que c'est le genre
d'incident dont un ministre du Travail
se passerait volontiers pour quelle
raison parce que sur un sujet aussi
important que celui-ci et Madame de
brossia j'ai regardé le passé et j'ai vu
bcassen pardon j'ai regarder le passé et
j'ai vu que malheureusement y compris
pour d'autres ministres du travail ça
n'était pas la première fois je souhaite
que ce soit la dernière fois car sur des
sujets aussi sensibles aussi nécessaires
au jugement objectif des uns et des
autres de l'opposition comme de la
majorité et particulièrement des
Français je ne veux pas que des chiffres
soient discutables soupçonnables comme
ils ont pu l'être par le passé ou comme
et j'en ai fait la remarque
immédiatement ils ont pu l'être pour le
mois d'août donc j'ai demandé la clarté
j'ai obtenu la clarté les
responsabilités sont établies et la
correction a été faite et monsieur le
sénateur que fait apparaître cette
correction elle fait apparaître que pour
la première fois pour la première fois
depuis 27 mois il y a eu une baisse du
nombre des chômeurs au mois d'août vous
auriez dû commencer par cela vous auriez
dû commencer par dire que pour la
première fois les Français ont vu le
nombre des chômeurs diminuer et que pour
le 4 mois consécutif le nombre des
chômeurs de moins de 25 ans a diminué 4
mois consécutifs ça ça fait une tendance
ça ça fait une courbe et ça fait une
cohérence c'est la cohérence de notre
politique oui nous avons mobilisé à la
fois les moyens de redonner du muscle à
l'économie française mais nous avons
mobilisé les politiques de l'emploi de
manière intelligente le chômage recule
ça n'est pas encore l'inversion un mois
ne fait pas une inversion mais cette
bataille nous la gagnerons et à la fin
de cette année l'inversion de la courbe
du chômage sera une réalité et j'espère
que vous en réjouz merci la parole est à
Monsieur Jacques cornan pour le groupe
socialiste monsieur le Président mes
chers
collègues ma question est à monsieur le
ministre de
l'Intérieur
37 c'est le nombre d'homicide dans le
département de la Guadeloupe depuis le
début de l'année c'est un taux de
mortalité qui nous donne le vertige et
qui interpelle au quotidien nos
populations c'est deux fois plus qu'à
Marseille et en Corse et ce dans la
quasi indifférence des pouvoirs publics
la police et la gendarmerie dans le
département de la Guadeloupe ont
enregistré cette année une augmentation
très inquiétante du nombre de faits
constatés d'atteintes volontaire à
l'intégrité
physique notre société est en perte de
valeur traditionnelle comme beaucoup
d'autres qui subissent les effets
pervers de la mondialisation la
Guadeloupe subit aujourd'hui une une
recudesence de l'immigration clandestine
une haosse inquiétante de la criminalité
et de la délinquence l'archipel est
aujourd'hui en proie au trafic en tout
genre les armes circulent librement et
impunément ces phénomènes sont les
conséquences notamment de la diminution
de l'effectif doiniier 342 en 2007 255
en 2013 de la suppression de la police a
frontière d'un effectif d'agent par
brigade très insuffisant 7 àli 6 à
Saint-François 5 et bientôt 4 à
mariegalante
l'insécurité est liée à la formation à
l'éducation et aussi au chômage fin
juillet le N nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi s'établissait à près de
68000 dont
8610 pour les moins de 25 ans et
38510 entre 25 et 49 ans soit
69,52 %. à Martinique et en Guyane le
terrible constat est identique le sujet
de l'insécurité doit donc être abordé
dans sa globalité c'est pourquoi il est
urgent associer le ministre du Travail
de l'éducation de la famille la
population demande du travail et il nous
appartient de trouver les voix et les
moyens pour créer de l'activité et donc
des emplois dans des secteurs porteurs
d'avenir les énergies renouvelables la
grransformation les métiers de
l'environnement les métiers de la mer le
tourisme d'ailleurs parlant du
tourisme il est tout à fait illusoire
d'envisager son développement durable
dans de telles conditions
d'insécurité l'Association des Maires
Guadeloupéens s'est réunie samedi
dernier et des pistes ont été dégagées
prendre des arrêtés municipaux
établissant des couvrefeu pour les
mineurs nous attendons des engagements
fort de l'État monsieur le ministre à
quand le retour de la police frontière à
Marie Galante quels sont les moyens
policiers douiniers que vous envisagez
pour remédier au problèm que nous
rencontrons très bien merci beaucoup
Monsieur Manuel
Vals
monsieur le sénateur Jacques Ornano il
n'y a pas de territoire oublié de la
République il peut pas y en avoir la
situation aux Antilles notamment dans
les outres m en général même s'il y a
des différences est une préoccupation
constante du gouvernement Victorin Lurel
évidemment s'en saisit dans toutes les
dimensions que vous avez évoqué
notamment dans la deuxè partie de votre
question le Premier ministre s'est rendu
aux chtil il y a quelques semaines
beaucoup de ministres d'ailleurs s'y
rendent et je serai moi-même sur ces
questions de sécurité dans une quinzaine
de jours vous le savez nous allons nous
rencontrer avant pour préparer ce
déplacement au en Martinique en
Guadeloupe et à Saint-Martin il faut
dire la vérité vous l'avez d'ailleurs
parfaitement décrite la situation dans
les Antilles est très difficil
particulièrement préoccupante et les
crimes les règlements de compte les
violences au sein des familles euh en
Guadeloupe comme à Saint-Martin sont
très préoccupantes avec des hausses tout
à fait considérables nous avons mis en
place depuis la fin du mois de juin 2013
un plan d'action conçu avec le ministre
des outresmèes mise en œuvre en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique afin de
faire reculer durablement les violences
les phénomènes de bande les cambriolages
les forces de l'ordre sont en train de
se réorganiser il faut nous attaquer aux
phénomènes et aux secteurs les plus
criminogènes
lutter contre l'économie souterrainee
qui joue un rôle tout à fait essentiel
et un groupe spécifique d'ailleurs a été
créé pour lutter contre les bandes et de
ce point de vue-là il faut mobiliser
tout le monde l'état bien sûr c'est sa
mission principale les collectivités
territorial mais également toute la
société car la seule réponse ne viendra
pas que des pouvoirs publics même si
elle est tout à fait essentielle pour
les raisons que vous rappelier mais il
faut aussi c'est vrai que toute la
société guadeloupéenne se mobilise le
Premier ministre l'a annoncé des
renforts d'effectifs sont programmés à
hauteur de 27 policiers pour la
Guadeloupe 25 pour la Martinique une
zone de sécurité prioritaire est mise en
place à pointapite les habîes et une
seconde sur les cinq quartiers de Fort
de France là aussi il s'agit de
mobiliser l'ensemble des forces mais je
peux vous dire mon attention et
l'occasion de ce déplacement nous
permettra je crois d'aller encore plus
loin pour être ensemble les plus
efficaces face à cette violence en tout
cas euh la métropole Paul c'est
parfaitement ce qu'elle doit aux
Antilles et notamment au département de
la Guadeloupe merci Monsieur Jean-Louis
Masson pour les
nonincrit la question se
ouais et pour monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur le ministre étant
sénateur non inscrit je vote toujours
librement en fonction de la qualité des
textes et de l'intérêt général ainsi
j'ai soutenu à 100 % le projet
d'interdiction des cumules abusifs de
mandat car j'estime que cette réforme
contribuera à démocratiser et à
moraliser la vie publique par contre je
tiens à vous faire part de ma profonde
réprobation au sujet d'une autre
orientation soutenu par le gouvernement
en l'espèce le transfert obligatoire des
compétences d'urbanisme des communes au
profit des
intercommunalités or le plan local
d'urbanisme c'est-à-dire le PLU est un
document fondamental car il permet aux
communes de décider de leur avenir les
communes sont déjà étranglées
financièrement si en plus elles ne
peuvent plus maîtriser leur
développement cela revient à les rayer
de la carte c'est d'autant plus grave
que dans les intercommunalités les
pouvoirs sont souvent détenus par la
ville centre de ce fait les communes
rurales périphériques risquent de se
voir imposer des HLM de 10 étages ou des
aires de stationnement pour nomades
plus généralement jusqu'à présent les
transferts de compétences au profit des
intercommunalités se faisaient sur la
base du volontarisme local en est
dictant un transfert obligatoire et
généralisé on crée un dangereux
précédent au détriment des communes
monsieur le ministre où est le respect
de la démocratie locale monsieur le
ministre est-ce que le gouvernement veut
la mort des
communes merci la parole à Madame Anne
Marie escfier ministre chargé de la
décentralisation merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur maçon
j'ai bien entendu votre inquiétude
concernant les intercommunalités et les
transferts de compétences qui pourrai
leur qui pourrai intervenir je voudrais
vous rassurer rappeler simplement que
depuis maintenant 20 ans avec la loi JX
en 198 12 ensuite en 99 avec la loi
Chevenement l'intercommunalité a été
mise en place et aujourd'hui je crois
que de façon unanime chacun en sent le
bienfait parce que
l'intercommunalité répond à trois
critères majeurs le premier c'est
répondre à un projet partagés entre les
collectivités territoriales c'est donc
la volonté de travailler ensemble le
deuxième c'est maîtriser les dépenses et
le troè objectif c'est l'efficacité au
bénéfice du citoyen alors j'entends bien
les inquiétudes qui peuvent être les
vôtres je voudrais vous rassurer vous
dire que dans le cadre du projet de loi
de finan 2014 nous travaillons avec
force et vigueur pour faire en sorte que
il y ait une véritable péréquation qui
puisse se mettre en place et permettre à
nos collectivités territorial à nos
communes de continuer à œuvrer et à
apporter sur le terrain pour les
citoyens les services dont ils ont
besoin merci mes chers collègues nous en
avons fini avec les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
16h15 pour la suite du projet de loi de
modernisation voilà donc pour cette
séance des questions d'actualité que
vous avez pu suivre en direct sur notre
antenne on se retrouve tout de suite
avec nos invités pour refaire ensemble
la
séance bonjour à tous merci de nous
rejoindre en direct du Sénat après la
séance des questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement cet après-midi à la haute
assemblée et bien nous revenons sur ces
thèmes d'actualité ensemble avec nos
invités nous allons parler travail du
dimanche et travail la nuit rythme
scolaire et puis aussi le 55e
anniversaire de notre constitution de la
5e République nos deux premiers invités
sont Annie David sénatrice communiste de
liser et présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales bonjour merci d'être
avec nous et puis Jean artui sénateur
triste bonjour à vous merci également
d'être sur ce plateau